bonsoir carnet monseigneur merci d'être
avec nous alors l'europe qui rouvre ses
frontières mais l'om est ce qui reste
malgré tout pessimiste vous en tant que
responsable d'agencé qu'est ce que vous
dites à vos clients aujourd'hui est ce
que vous y voyez un peu plus clair vos m
mais en fait ça dépend de comment vous
dire en fonction des pays dans lesquels
les clients comptent aller on essaie de
se renseigner en fonction des mesures
prises qu'ils en place par chaque
gouvernement et on prend les décisions
joue au jour le jour
alors effectivement la liste a été
dévoilée il ya quinze pays qui sont
c'était aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
français mais on prévient qu'elle peut
être réviser toutes les deux semaines ça
veut dire beaucoup d'incertitudes même
autour de ces destinations
beaucoup d'incertitudes parce que par
exemple je vais prendre le donc
l'exemple de la grèce
il ya encore une semaine on savait que
la grèce était et est prête à ouvrir à
partir du 1er juillet sauf que là donc
depuis hier ils ont mis en place un
système de questionnaire avec un qr code
que les clients devront avoir à leur
arrivée et ça déterminera s'ils doivent
être testés donc vous voyez c'est tous
les jours des nouvelles des nouvelles
mises en place par les pays
c'est un petit peu difficile à à mettre
fin à expliquer aux clients si vous
voulez ça augmente leur crainte je
trouve et pour nous aussi parce que
néanmoins c'est pas facile parce qu'il
faut pouvoir le gérer pour toutes les
destinations en tout cas pour ma part je
fais le monde entier donc il faut se
renseigner pour chaque pays du monde
entier alors il ya quinze destinations
effectivement que n'ont rien à voir les
unes que les autres un jeu j'en suis
quelques-unes l'algérie l'australie le
canada la géorgie le ronde à la serbie
la corée du sud la thaïlande tunisie
uruguay pour vous en tant qu agence de
voyages
est ce qu'il ya une logique qui est
respectée dans ces destinations non
encore une fois c'est la france qui
prend la décision d'accueillir les
résidents de ces destinations comme
l'australie le rwanda ou d'autres
destinations que vous avez pu évoquer
par contre ça veut pas dire que les
autres destinations enfin je vous prends
l'exemple de l'australie par exemple ça
peut pas dire que les australiens eux or
en droit de quitter leur pays pour venir
en europe
nous on va les accepter mais sous
certaines conditions
mais par contre les australiens eux
n'auront pas le droit de quitter le pays
pareil pour nous il est important de le
préciser exactement aujourd'hui
clairement quels sont les pays dits peu
tout terrain où les français ne
prendrons pas de risque pour leurs
vacances
je dirais l'espagne l'italie la france
bien sûr
après ça peut être la belgique ce peut
être l'allemagne c'est peut-être le
moment de découvrir des destinations on
n'aurait pas l'habitude mais voilà je
dirais plutôt en tout cas ces derniers
jours les clients quand même beaucoup de
craintes
donc je dois avouer que il est
préférable de tête de rester dans
l'espace schengen tout le monde l'espace
schengen ou carrément la france c'était
en tout cas le souhait du gouvernement
clairement aujourd'hui les français
affichent leur préférence pour leur
propre pays où ils ne se sont pas encore
en majorité décidée pour leurs vacances
d'été
pas tous pas tous y en a beaucoup qui
sont prêts à réserver pour enfin en
dehors de la france
par contre ça va plus tout est du las
minutes je pense c'est à dire de nu
lastminute les gens vont vraiment se
décider au tout dernier moment avec
peut-être des tarifs préférentiels ou au
contraire les hôteliers vont vouloir
peut-être se rattraper de leurs pertes à
quoi doit-on s'attendre au niveau des
tarifs au niveau des tarifs c'est
possible que des prix baissent après
selon certaines destinations si vous
prenez par exemple la grèce par contre
je doute que les plus vraiment baisse
sachant que des dés par exemple les
allemands ou les roumains et des russes
sont très
et son très enclins à aller en grèce et
pour le coup le prix je doute que ça les
frênes vraiment par contre pour les
français c'est pas tant une question
prix c'est une question plutôt de santé
les conditions dans lesquelles ils
peuvent être amenés à être à être
acceptés par le pays si c'est pour aller
en grèce une semaine deux semaines
et puis à l'arrivée on vous dit que vous
avez un test à faire et que vous êtes
positif il va falloir faire une 14/n une
certaine on imagine que ce n'est pas
évident clairement haut niveau voilà pas
tarifs mais au niveau quand on a pris un
voyage c'est extrêmement compliqué on
imagine les conditions de remboursement
comment ça se passe comment vous gérez
ça vous en tant qu'agence il ya des
décrets on suppose mais c'est compliqué
à mettre en oeuvre
alors après il ya leur donnant du 25
mars qui qui régule les les voyages à
forfait après pour nous c'est une c'est
une négociation qui doit se passer avec
chaque fournisseur soit avec le tour
operator soit avec l'hôtelier certains
hôteliers ne sont pas du tout enclin à
vouloir faire des remboursements ou il
préfère envisager d avoir pour être sûr
que les clients vont revenir chez eux
néanmoins mis en france on est régulée
par l'ordonnancé donc on doit pouvoir
proposer aux clients un à voir qui va
durer 18 mois est au bout des 18 mois le
client pourra être remboursé merci
beaucoup caroline seigneur d'avoir été
avec nous et de nous avoir tenté d'y
voir plus clair sur ce qui nous attend
cet été salaire d'un confluent encore en
tout cas merci à vous